advances in Internet and mobile
technology have been the driving force
in our modern world these technological
advances have bolstered economies aided
social development and assisted
governments worldwide but those same
advances have also created new
opportunities for criminals to place our
safety and security in danger the
internet was founded on the idea of
connecting computers together so that
the computers could talk to other
computers right in the earliest days
there was a trust relationship among
those computers and among the people who
are using those computers but as the
internet grew from four sites to four
billion sites we can't make such
assumptions about trust anymore each
technological advance comes with it new
opportunities for cyber criminals with
their goals of power chaos and disorder
cyber terrorist targets can afflict
every aspect of our daily lives the
results can lead to identity theft
corporate network corruption hijacking
of critical communication systems and
much much more
no nation no business no individual can
take on the challenges of cybersecurity
alone because of that Carnegie Mellon
University Scilab has developed a
collaborative center for cybersecurity
research and development that is among
the world's finest that covers a space
that nobody does in the world today in
combining security research with
dependability research human-computer
interfaces privacy salad takes a broad
three-pronged approach to dealing with
security problems yeah
and it really has to if you're gonna
solve the problem so involved in that
our technology which is sort of stuff
that I work on now policy because some
of these things are actually going to
require national level decisions to be
made about what's going to be okay and
what's not going to be okay and
awareness because everybody has a role
in in computer security Scilab has
joined forces with over 40 corporations
representing sectors such as information
technology finance and defense these
partnerships are essential to providing
valuable insight into the challenges
that cyber security threats posed in
real
the corporate parkas are are invaluable
industry helps us focus on what the
market wants what the DoD wants what
their customers want
researchers have a mission to work on
problems that others don't the industry
hasn't addressed yet we have two or
three steps ahead of the industry we're
going to create new technologies that
are going to make computer security work
better
somebody has to actually take that from
research to product and somebody has to
give us feedback and we get that from
our regular interactions with our
corporate or corporate partners 9/11
showed us all that the dangers we face
in the modern world are new challenging
and very difficult to pinpoint and
manage there was a need to be able to
identify possible known or suspected
terrorists there to be beefed up the
information sharing helped with the
public policy or with the government
work to try to get more technology out
there one element critical to scylab
success has been its multidisciplinary
approach Carnegie Mellon's culture
allows Scilab to leverage some of the
nation's most well respected educators
and research scientists across various
disciplines to ensure that scilab
solutions are not only technologically
sound but also meet the divergent needs
of Management public policy forensic
science and various other entities the
great thing about CMU is that we've set
up a laboratory here at SCI lab where we
have economists risk analysis
human-computer interaction experts all
sitting side by side with computer
scientists and engineers and this allows
us to really look at the problem in a
much more holistic way through that
relationship the technology we develop
in the lab is better targeted to the
needs of the world and our partners in
the world understand what's coming
what's likely to happen what
expectations can they have in these
first post 9/11 years scilab has made
critical advances in education
biometrics
to where assurance privacy and much more
to address these modern concerns as a
result we are all more aware of the
threats we face while also having better
technology in place to protect us
there's a real threat that threat was
not just in two continents away that
threat was visibly here in the US soil
what we try to do is focus in on key
technologies what's going to have the
highest impact that will really make a
difference what has made Carnegie Mellon
scy-lab so successful is its
unparalleled team of faculty and
research staff and it's critical
partnerships with public and private
groups the corporate partnerships are
really a good way for us to be able to
understand the real needs of companies
and to help get our work out into the
real world for decades Carnegie Mellon
has been a leader in technology
engineering business and scientific
discovery scilab continues the
university's legacy of success by being
yet another valuable agent of progress
and change critical to our collective
safety security and well-being scilab
has the perfect home in Carnegie Mellon
it brings together people from across
the university and that's really the
philosophy of Carnegie Mellon it really
leads to a lot of entrepreneurial
efforts a lot of innovation it's really
an exciting time to be part of scilab I
think that over the next five to ten
years Scilab is going to continue to
grow as new problems emerge I think
we're in a really good position to
tackle whatever comes in front of us the
many faces of cyber terrorism may in
fact be the most dangerous threats in
our world today
scilab is uniquely positioned to
continue to meet these threats head-on
by developing solutions necessary to
ensure our well-being today and tomorrow
many innovative developments are
happening here at carnegie-mellon Scilab
but our work has just begun every day
new threats to our cybersecurity arise
scilab is uniquely positioned to be a
leader in developing next-generation
computing and communication technologies
that will combat cyber threats
fundamental to this success is the
commitment and support of our public and
private partners together we are making
an enormous difference but now more than
ever we must work together to expand
these partnerships and to develop new
ones we must build upon the
accomplishments of a research and
educational efforts it is not only
essential to Carnegie Mellon scylab
success but most importantly it is
critical to our nation's well-being and
safety
you